Hello everyone, I am Nilanjan, a PhD research scholar from CCDS, IIT Kharagpur and today
I am going to take your deep learning applications in computer vision hands on.
And before starting, I am just going to clarify some of the doubts that you are having that
I heard regarding some of the evaluations of the assignments and the quizzes.
So considering the quizzes, we have forwarded each of the quizzes, any any questions that
you are having forwarded it to a particular professor who is responsible for that particular
quiz, right.
So it will be based on different professors who have given the quizzes and they will be
solving your issue directly.
So we have just forwarded it to them, so it will take some time before they can respond
and you will get the feedbacks.
And there are some issue with the programming assignments also that I came to know and like
maybe some of the students got zero and you are having doubts like your code is running
but yet you are not getting the same, you are not getting the good score.
So the issue here is I am just going to point out is that each of this programming assignment
is being calculated automatically.
So there are some test cases, probably you have been given some test cases as well in
the question paper.
But during this testing part where you are given the scores, we are not using that particular
evaluation criteria that that you have been given in the question paper.
Basically we have different set of test and that particular test, I think it will be forwarded
to you once the course is over basically the programming assignment is over, you will get
like which particular test cases have been used to evaluate their assignments.
Now like there could be like 5 test cases and maybe in some of the programming assignments
we have selected all the 5 test cases.
So in that case if you are for example program passes let us say 5 out of 5, you get a hundred
score and it reduces as you get a lower number of passes.
So this is for all the programming assignments.
And there are some programming assignments where we pick just one test case and that is
due to the limited time that we have to evaluate the programming assignments.
Because some of the assignments for example deep learning models or machine learning models
that take huge amount of time if you want to like test so many test cases.
So in that case we pick a single test case from that and we evaluate.
So you can understand if it is a machine learning or deep learning kind of assignment that you
are solving.
So any of the test cases if it fails that means there is a probability that you might get 0.
So that you must know and all of these are very much transparent and we are sharing all
the like test cases with you once you are submitting the assignments.
And if you are having any doubts with the test cases of course you can reach out and we can
have a discussion on that.
So let us start our today's session and today we are going to as I told you discuss on the
computer vision and you can see that I have given a picture here.
So giving you a brief outline on what you will be able to do once this class is over.
So we have an MNIST dataset which is a number written in handwritten format and you can
see that there are 0 to 9 digits that has been given.
And the idea here is if a handwritten digit is given then what will be its class and the
class is basically nothing but its actual number.
So 0 represents 0, 1 represents 1, 9 represents 9 it is as simple as that.
So this is basically classification task and any classification task that you have done
till now you know that we always need to have a training and testing set.
So we will see that how we can import this MNIST dataset later part and then we will
see that how we can devise this training partition and this testing partition separately.
So basically this dataset will be partitioned into two sections where we will have this
training and testing data and now we will pass it to a convolutional neural network.
And this convolutional neural network as you can understand is basically two things combined.
So first is the feature extraction part where you extract the features from the image and
once this features are extracted we get to a dense classification layer where you just
classify to different classes.
So you can understand you can give this training data through the model and once you have this
training data the model can actually extract the features from this particular this first
section which is the feature extraction section and the classification section.
And you can see that both of them are together so these are combined shared weights and once
you are training the model the inter model is getting trained that means the feature
extractor is also getting trained as well as this dense layer which is the fully connected
layer which classifies.
So the entire thing trains that is why the CNNs are very, very improved over any of the
previous methods that we have seen like using the machine learning methods where we have
to extract the features separately for each of the task.
So we will see that how we can like work with this CNN models and which models are there.
But before starting that we want to discuss about basically I want to discuss about this
image thing what is an image if you do not know what is an image it is difficult to do
some intensive tasks.
So most use task you can understand the classification task or any of the regression task that you
have done till now is very easy to perform because there are APIs that you can directly
call there are libraries that you can directly use and these libraries you can just import
them you can pass the training data and the testing data even they have like the training
and testing partition functions also.
And you can just give that data and it will give you the output as simple as that you have
to have a system that you can run a model like this as easy as that.
But when you are doing some research or doing some actual work in this field then you must
know that how this model works or at least the basics of the model so that you can like
go ahead and do some interesting stuff.
So let us see what we can do.
So initially I will just show you like okay let us just so I am storing all the data in
Google Drive at this moment because we are sharing this through Collab.
But before getting started I am just going so let the Google Drive load so I am just
going to show you that probably you have received a link of my GitHub page where you can just
go to this particular section DL applications and computer vision hands on.
You can just go there this link here we have provided you this link just take your messages.
And once you have this you will have this ipython file this assignment.pdf and this data.zip.
So these are a few of the things that is present here and you can see that this data you can
directly download or in this python file also if you are just running this it will download
it automatically if you do not have that locally.
So if you are able to download it you can just download it or you can just directly
run it and I will always recommend that you must copy this code and run it in your environment
or you can just open it in Collab and start it.
So I know that you have already done the machine learning programs and I have also shown you
that how Google Drive can be connected.
So it is a simple one liner code that we use which is basically Google Collab import drive
and we just mount the drive and the location we need to just provide.
So this is the very essential thing that we need to do for this particular session.
You can have your local system also if you are having running it in your local machine
you can just store it any place in your drive and just share the location of the image files
and all.
So this is one of the image that I have created I will show you the image from here only.
So let us just show this image to you okay not now.
So this is the image and how we can load this image.
So my image is stored in this particular location and I use this SK image library.
Let us go to the SK image library you can see here.
So it is essentially the same extension of the scikit-learn library which you use for
machine learning but this scikit image is specifically designed for all the functions
that you can get for image processing.
So this is also a very widely used library for image processing.
You can go ahead and check all the things that are present here.
So we are going to use this library and you can import this library here by this command
where you give this from SK image which is that particular library import I/O.
So I was basically handles the input output operations from this library.
So my image is a variable where I am going to store this image and I will just show you
this image after some time.
So to read this image I am just giving you that I/O.imread which is a function which takes
the location parameter which takes this location parameter and it prints the output.
So let us first print this thing which is the data type of this particular image file right.
So let us run this.
So you see that we are having a data type of unsigned integer 8.
So what does it mean that this image is essentially a matrix of integer values.
And ok let us see what is the range of the values that this integer value can hold basically
it is 2 to the power 8 which is 256 that means each of the pixels can have a value that ranges
between 0 and 255 so as simple as that.
So why this is important that you will be understanding after some time.
So let us print the image dimensions.
So you can see that I have loaded this image and this image is an object of this SK image
library and you can directly give some functions to it.
For example this safe function right or this data type function d type function.
So if you give my image dot safe it will give you the output dimensions directly.
So let us see what is the output dimension.
So the dimension of this image is kind of random because I have made it in a random way.
So it is 6 to 2 into 1 0 0 1 into 3.
So what does this mean?
This means that it is the height of this image which is 6 to 2 1 0 0 1 which is the width
of the image and 3 is the channels.
What are the channels here?
So this is a colored image and the 3 channel represents RGB basically the red, green and
blue values associated with each of this images.
Now we can just print this image.
Let us see what printing this image gives us.
So you can understand this printing this image gives us a matrix of like lots of numbers
right.
So what does this numbers actually mean is that these are the numerical representation
of these dimensions right.
So for each value we are having this 3 RGB values.
So this is 1 pixel.
So this selected thing is 1 pixel where 1 is ranging from 0 to 255 for red, another is
for green and another is for blue.
So these are the representation of the images.
Not much interesting as I can understand but you have to know this if you are going to
do some kind of analytical task later on.
So this is how an image is formatted.
So you have this image and now I am just going to display this image.
So basically I am just going to show this image.
Now it is going to get some more interesting.
So matplotlib similarly we have used this library for plotting various graphs.
So here we will use that same library for plotting the image or basically displaying
the image.
So from matplotlib we are going to import this pi plot which we have done earlier and
we are naming it as PLT for shorter version and it is quite standard we use it always.
So plt.imshow is another function that actually prints the images or show the images right.
So we are just going to pass this image object from a scalar library and we can just run
it and we can see that the image gets printed.
So let us see what is this image.
So this is an image that I have created in paint and you can see that the dimensions are given
in this width values and the height values are given here and this is an image of different
colors and some borders something like that and we are going to use this image for different
kind of testing before we move on to this neural network or convolutional neural network
stuff.
So here I am just going to see what are the minimum values of the pixels that we have
here and the maximum values of the pixel.
So for that it is very very easy we are just going to take that my image variable and we
are going to get the minimum and the maximum functions and let us see.
So it is basically ranging from 0 to 255.
So as we discussed now there is an interesting part and this is very very important because
this is the night now an integer based image.
So we have seen that this is an unsigned integer matrix.
But with unsigned integer matrix it is very difficult to formulate some mathematical operations
on this.
It is possible but it will be very difficult.
For that we solve it using float images or the values will be represented in float format.
So let us see how we can do that.
So this SK image library directly provides us with an IMG as float.
So basically we want to convert the image to float from any other like type.
So here it is we have imported this and it is as simple as just passing this my image
object to this function of IMG as float and I am storing it as my float image right.
So I am just going to print my float image minimum and maximum values that we did earlier
for this one where we have this 0 and 255 value.
And we are going to print the data type as well just like the previous time.
And let us see what we get here is we get 0.0 and 1.0.
So these are very simple steps you can just copy this parts from this link that we have
provided and you can run this easily.
So I think yeah so one more important thing is that we must connect to a GPU environment
as you can see here I have connected to T4 environment.
You also must do that because we are going to work with some deep learning models which
training will take more time if you are using CPU.
So here we are getting 0 and 0 1.0 what does this mean this means that now the pixel values
each of the pixel values instead of ranging from 0 to 255 now ranges between 0 and 1.
So now it is much easier for you to do mathematical operations on this floating point values.
So this plot.image so again shows the image but right now I am just going to show you
this my float image and you will see that this is the exact same image that we had earlier.
Just the image internal formatting is changed from integer to float but the actual image
has no change because it is the same image right.
So let us see what are the mathematical operations that I was talking about right.
So it is very very simple to do.
So let us just keep a copy of our original image I am just zooming a bit for simplicity.
So you can see that I am just copying this using this line of code you are probably know
that there is a copy function where which you can use to copy various objects in python
and if you do not keep a copy of it the original variable might change.
So we have just copied this and let us call it my dark image and I am just copying this
my float image.
So I am taking the float version of the image that we have created and what I am doing now
is that my dark image now becomes 0.5 into my dark image.
What does this mean?
We are multiplying 0.5 to each and every value that is present in the matrix of the image.
So essentially previously our image has a range of 0 and 1 for this version where we
are having this float version and now you will see that if you multiply it by 0.5 every
value will be like half right.
So if it is 1 it will become 0.5 if it is let us say 0 it will become 0.
So it will just range the values like that and what significant changes we will have
will have a darker version of the image the brightness will reduce.
Let us see what we get here is that now so I am just printing this minimum and maximum
values for your help so it is 0 and 0.5 instead of 0 and 1 right.
So let us print this my dark image and see what we get here so you see that previously
we had an image which is having a higher brightness but now the image is darker right.
So as simple as that so you can understand what kind of mathematical operations I was
talking about you can do any kind of mathematical operations on this matrix and you will get
a similar kind of output that you want.
So you can change this 0.5 to a different degree and you can get different versions of this
brightness of the images as simple as that right.
So in deep learning models there are some more complex operations that we will see you
have already gone through this theory class and you have already seen that there is stride
there is filter there are so many things and all of those are mathematical operations and
we do it via this techniques only.
So once we have this darker image now I am just going to add a filter to it just to show
you that how this works.
So again I am just making a copy of this image which is this my filter image and I am calling
it as my filter image and now I am taking this my filter image and giving it some range
let us see what are the range.
So this is the range for this height object this is the range for the width of so you
have to understand that it is always height then width and then the channels so we try
to keep that consistent.
So this is the height that we are considering so 200 to 500 right and you will see that
the maximum value we have already calculated for the height in the dimensions.
So in this dimension you will see that the dimension of this image we have calculated
is 622 and the width of the image is 1001 so we are within this range.
So we are trying to create some filter in this particular location as you can understand.
So let us see how we can do that yeah so here you see we are just giving a range of values.
So this is the height that we are considering for this filter right so this is a fixed height
and now this is the width again a fixed width.
So how we can provide a range so 200 then colon and then we are just giving this 500
value.
So if you give this value that means it ranges from 200 to 500 this is the height and this
is the width and why these are so important that we will discuss in the next coding part
right.
So and this is what does this mean this mean all the channels are considered here and my
filter image again I am considering that particular part.
So what I am doing here is essentially I am replacing my filter image and essentially
this part of the image which is a subsection of the image by this section we are just replacing
this part with this part of the image.
And what is the thing that we are replacing with it is the exact same image it is the exact
same location but with a lower value of brightness.
So all the values are cut off to 0.3 percent of the original image.
So if we do that there is an expectation that this particular portion of the image will
become darker where the rest of the image will be same.
So let us see what we get so we have just plotted the image directly here so you see
that we get a black spot in the middle which is a rectangular in size and the dimension
is given here which looks something like this right.
So this actually helps us to create a simple filter as you can understand this is a very
simple filter that we have created and this is a darkening filter.
So filters so the definition of filter might not be clear to many of you.
So just to give you an idea a filter is nothing but that gives you what you need and does
not give you what you do not need it is as simple as that.
For example in sunny days we use sunglasses and the sunglasses block the sun rays and
the ultraviolet rays right so it darkens it.
So it does not allow the sunlight to enter here also filter does mean the exact same
thing.
So whatever we want we can pass it through and whatever we do not want we do not want
to pass it through.
So we want to make a filter here for this particular purpose we are making a filter
which reduces the brightness that means we do not want much of the light coming through
this portion.
So this is the idea of this particular filter and convolutional neural networks in the same
way uses this filter.
So these filters are used by convolutional neural networks to pass some features and
to restrict some features that way this kind of feature extraction takes place.
Now let us just consider the same code and we are just making minor changes here.
So the minor change here is only this channel right.
So here we are just having this same exact same code but now I am just changing this
channel.
So now only one channel will be affected instead of all the channels and which is this channel
this is the last channel 2.
So there are 3 channels 0, 1 and 2 here right.
So let us just see what we are doing we are doing the exact same operation but the input
channel is 0.
Basically we are changing this image on this filter and the output filter will be affected
on the second filter.
So this is also a very simple operation.
So I am going to show you that how this kind of filters can affect.
So you see that this is one filter that we have created right now and it allows or it
passes this through an yellow filter.
So if you pass an yellow colored light or yellow colored filter these lights will be
passed.
The white becomes yellow you can see that the white feature was there which now has translated
to yellow.
So it is our new feature this blue became green.
So as you know that if you just combine blue color and yellow color you get a green color
and similarly for all of this you can see that you are able to get a filter that gives
you if it is an yellow it gives you the features of that yellow filter.
So this is very simple example and easy to understand example for image processing tasks.
Now let us just create a sliding filter and this is what happens in like the convolutional
neural networks right.
So just to give you an idea I am just going to show you here that what happens in this
convolutional layers.
So you have this image you have this image here and this image what we do is we so let
us say this is an image of our digit of 0 and we are going to read this image.
So we first have to consider a filter size.
So there will be a filter size and the filter size represents the size of the filter that
we are using.
So what this filters essentially do we can use any filter which is the same size as the
image also right.
So we can use this filter which is exactly the same size of the image then what is the
difference.
The difference is that if you use a smaller filter size so this for example this one and
then you slide it through this image basically you slide it like through some strides again
you are sliding it through some strides.
What you are essentially getting you are getting some localized features from here.
So from each of this filter striding you are getting some localized features whereas if
you use this entire filter together you might not get that enough information.
So this filters will give you a very detailed feature extraction and this helps the model
to learn quite faster also.
That is why this filter techniques comes into play in convolutional neural network.
As in the theory class it was explaining explained that if you take a filter like this.
So if this is a filter the center values are calculated.
So what does this mean?
This means that you are taking all this row values so there are let us say many values
in this matrix and you are essentially trying to smaller it down or basically extract the
features from it and you are trying to make it a single feature.
So you had let us say a matrix of dimension 3 cross 3 and you will end up having a matrix
of just one dimension like 1 cross 1 right.
So this is how we are going to do and I am just going to show you that how these kind
of filters you can create by your own and why it is required at least.
Let us see in this code so it is very very simple to do that.
Let us just run this code and this is the exact same kind of code that we were working
with till now.
So I am just copying this float image now in sliding filter image variable and I am
just taking this image dot shape which gives me this three different values which is the
height width and depth.
Let us see what are the values so these are the exact same values that we got right ok.
So now what I want is I want to just create a sliding window kind of thing.
We have previously created this window but now I am just going to create a sliding window
to show you an example.
So this is the sliding window filter.
So I am just importing time why this is required I will just tell you in some time.
So this is again this map plot pie plot but here what we are going to do is we are going
to take two different classes from here which is this I am show and show.
So these two classes I am importing separately and this is required because we are just going
to iteratively print some of these images.
I will maybe not able to print the entire image but probably we will get an idea what
is happening.
So here we are taking some parameters and you have to understand these parameters very well
because you will see that these similar kind of parameters will be using in this convolutional
neural network models that we will be working on.
So this is this H stride.
So H stride means here this horizontal stride.
So stride means how much skips you are taking for this particular filters in each step.
So this H stride gives you the stride values for horizontal values and V stride gives you
the similar kind of thing for this vertical values.
So V stride stands for the vertical value and we are taking 50 for this particular image
and let us consider this filter size.
Now filter size as you are able to see that we already created one filter earlier and that
was our rectangular kind of feature but right now we are considering only a square kind
of filter.
In many models you will see that we are already using this square kind of feature.
So we are just giving only one dimension it is nothing but 100 cross 100 right.
So this filter size if we take that and this V stride and H stride we consider then we
can go ahead and create a very simple pipe or like a flow right and this flow is nothing
but we are creating an iteration of this height value.
So essentially if I just show you this image so we are passing from so if this is the portion
that we are working on so we are passing from here to this part then here to this part and
here to this part so there are these three different stages.
And what we need is we want to pass this first row we have one to just move through this
first row and you have already done this kind of similar python like codes right.
So we are just going to move from this and this is nothing but a matrix that that you
must follow and these are the values of maybe 1, 2, 3, 4 and so on again 1, 2, 3, 4 so these
are the numbers values and we are just going to pass from this side to this side again
this side to this side again this side to this side right.
And if you are going to do that we are going to take this step first basically we are going
to traverse this width right and we are followed by that we are going to traverse this height.
So we are just doing that same thing in this code what we are doing is we are just sliding
through this width value where we have this width and this h stride.
Now you can see that this h stride value is nothing but this horizontal stride we are
keeping this value same for this particular section and you can always change this.
This particular part is not present in your code in your shared library you will get this
later on.
But the thing is that you this is just for your visualizations or try to see what I am
doing here you do not need to code because you have already coded this part that is essentially
enough you do not need to do any coding you just need to see this part and how this is
done.
So here the j value actually represents the horizontal movement right so the horizontal
movement is represented by j and this vertical movement that we are coming from top to bottom
of this image matrix it is represented by i.
And what does this mean?
In this mean that we are starting from a value of 0 so we are starting from the extreme left
and we are going so for this one we are starting from this extreme left and we are moving to
this maximum width of the image which is basically the width of the image.
And we are skipping some of the portions which is the stride, stride means skips some of
the values right and this stride value each stride is for the horizontal one and we did
the exact same thing for this vertical one right.
So for this vertical one what we have done is we have started from 0 basically top and
we are going to the bottom basically height of this image.
And then we are going to stride it through this v stride variable which is again considered
as 50 here so both of them are same.
Now let us consider this sliding filter image this was the previous thing that we are doing
now we are replacing this part of the image which part of the image this particular part
of the image and we are replacing it by the same portion of the image and just multiplying
it by 0.5.
So we are going to check by a reduced like darkening filter we can say.
So what is the dimension here now?
You can see we start from i which is the height value that we have taken so this is this part
is for height we all know that right.
So we are starting from this i and we are taking from i to filter size i plus filter
size so it takes the inter size of the filter right so this becomes your vertical dimension.
Similarly we can get our horizontal dimension which is represented in j to j plus filter
size and the filter size is same which is 100 we have taken and we have just changing
the exact same portion of that image and we are multiplying it by 0.5 basically reducing
that part of the image.
And we are going to show this image by this imshow and then giving this variable name
basically sliding filter image and show and as I was telling you that what is the use
of this time I am just giving this time.slip function which is basically it waits before
executing the next step to one second so that we can see the different steps that it is making.
So this is a very interesting code you can just use it in many ways right and this gives
you an analytical idea on how this sliding and filtering thing works in convolutional
neural network.
So let us run this code I am not going to run it for the entire time so you see that
we are getting new images every time you see that we are getting new image every time right.
And this image you can see that the filter is getting moved from left to right side.
And once you get through all this features basically all this entire image you get one
feature of that particular image and as many number of filters you are having you will get
that many number of features we will see that in some time so I think I can stop this.
So you can see what we have done here so if I just go to this very top of this image just
to show you you see this is the first image that is created this is the first filter right
this is the first filter and we have probably if you are doing some neural network stuff
we will just keep this filter value stored in somewhere.
And once we have this all this filtered value together we can just combine them to get the
particular feature.
So here this is one filter and in the next step you see that we have just moved from
left to right stride of 50 I think right we have taken the stride 50 and since we have
moved to this part this part becomes more darker why this part becomes more darker because
it is more attentive.
So we have attended this portion more times that is why it is much darker because there
is already a filter there right and again we if we move just downwards you will see
that the filter again moved to its right side and it is capturing all these features and
if you just keep on moving you will see that we are essentially getting this filter moved
from left to right side.
And once this entire thing is done once we have moved to till the very end of this first
row of this image you will see that we will reach to the next line so here.
So here what we have done we have just moved through this entire first row of this matrix
and then we have come to the second row.
And you will see that the stride which is the basically the vertical stride is also we
have considered 50 and it has moved from 0 to 50 now.
And then again it will just run for this particular filter size and this will continue as we keep
on running this loop.
So once you have this entire image if you have this entire image then you will see that
you can store this filter and you can have this version of this feature that you can
use in some of the aspect of this model.
So essentially we have gone through this initial portion which was required for understanding
how images can be represented in floating format and why it is important, how a basic
filter can be used and how the filter can be moved in a manner that a convolution neural
network does.
And here there are various parameters like the stride parameter, the filter size and
how many number of filters.
So basically the number of filters you can understand that here there is only one filter
that we have used and which is the darkening filter as we have discussed.
But in reality you will be using multiple filters and this multiple filters will give
you multiple features from your model.
So here are the different things.
Now let us start with a model of convolutional neural network.
It is an AlexNet, you will get this information anywhere.
So what is an AlexNet?
It is basically a very famous model and it is used by like almost many people if they
are starting their research in this image processing field and this AlexNet is essentially
a convolutional neural network which has different architecture format that we will discuss.
Again it has this two different sections which is the feature extraction section where we
have this input, the different convolutional layers, the pooling layers and once we have
that we will pass it to a dense classification layer or a fully connected layer and we will
finally have a classification output layers.
So let us start with this libraries that we are going to import and if you are just new
to this, you just go to this Torch library.
It is widely used for deep learning models and this model, this particular library you
will be using for various natural language processing tasks and all the different tasks
that you can think of using deep learning.
So this is a very important library that we will be using from now on and it gives you
more functions that you need for any task that is involved in this deep learning classes.
So we are just going to import all these different classes and I will discuss all these different
classes in each of the sections.
This is just the import section and you must import this Torch library here and let us start
by seeding this.
So what is this seed?
So torch.manual seed we have given a value of 42.
What does this mean?
This means that we are going to seed this value basically we are going to freeze the
operations that the model is performing.
So as you can understand these are mathematical models, there are some random generations taking
place in many places and this random generations will give you different output every time.
So even if the model is same, even if the data set is same, you might not get the same
output every time but for a testing environment we must make sure that the output that we
are getting is quite fixed and this gives us that feature basically we can seed this
so that any kind of random generations will take place will be exactly same as the previous
one.
So torch.manual seed and we can give any integer value and it will try to keep that frozen
state for any of the random generations.
So once we have gone through that we will give this data path.
Now what is this data path data path is nothing but where we have stored this data and as
I told you that I have shared this data in this collab where data.zip is there you can
just copy it and unzip it in your local drive or in your Google drive and it will work and
if you are not doing that you can just keep a function download equals to 2 that will
be going.
So it will download the code for you or the data set for you.
So let us first see what the code means here.
So this is this data path we have given this location of the data that we are talking about.
Now this trans actually stores the transformation of this values.
So this transpose is actually a transpose function or transforms function that we have
imported here you can see here.
So it is from this torch vision particular library and from this transforms class we
are just importing this transforms function right.
This transforms function what it do is basically normalizes the values that we are providing
it to the model.
Now normalization why is it important we have already discussed that is why we were talking
about some mathematical stuffs previously because those were very very important in real life.
So you will see that in a single line code you can do that but the idea here is that
you might not get the idea if you are using the code directly.
That is why we must know that how the things are working and this transformation function
exactly does the same thing that we have done previously.
We have converted this values to some normalizations.
Now this trans is an object basically it takes care of this transformation and the transformation
here is a normalized transformation between 0.5 and 1 right.
So we are excluding values which is anything lower than 0.5 and this is the training set.
So we are just going to store our training data in this full trained set variable and
it is very very simple to get this data sets also.
So d set is again another function that is provided by this torch vision data sets class
and you can directly give some parameters and get the data set.
So d set already gives you this MNIST class which takes the values of root which is the
data path we have already discussed and this train value is true why what does this mean
it will directly convert it to a training set and this transform function if we want
to transform it in some way.
So this I have shown you you might not transform it anyways but this is just for showing you
like how this thing works directly without writing any special code that we did earlier
right.
So we had to code everything and that time but here you can just pass this parameters
and it will work and then it takes again a parameter of download equals to true which
means that it will just start the download for this particular file.
So yeah so it will create this training set here and if you just say that train equals
to false it will create a testing set as simple as that and nothing else is changed you can
see we need to do the same transformation for the training set as well as the testing
set.
So it should not be like the training set is transformed in some way but the test set
is in a different way right.
And there is another parameter which is the batch size and this is the very very important
parameter in any of the models that we will be working on in deep learning.
So you can see that we have considered a batch size of 16 this batch size is very very interesting
to like find for each of the systems because this is system dependent.
You cannot just give your 200 right so if you give it 200 it will take that many resources.
So as you increase this value the batch size it exponentially increases the memory consumption
but the thing is that if you increase this batch size you get a positive effect on the
model training also because you are taking more data together and you are trying to learn
the more data parameters.
So what is the difference between this batch size smaller batch size and the larger batch
size here is that if you are taking a smaller batch size and if you have a system that is
having lower resources of course you can run it in a lower batch size.
The difference in the scores or model training will be very very insignificant but of course
if you are using a very large data set you are using a large batch size and you are comparing
it to a large data set with a small batch size it will take more time and the training will
be less effective so this is how it transforms it to.
So this batch size you have to fix it as per your system environment.
In Google Colab the batch size of 16 per m nest is quite good that we have seen.
So let us just see what is in the training data set let us just see what we get ok sorry
I have not run this.
So here we are going to store we will see that this training data set is nothing but
there will be images of different classes as we told in MNIST.
So there will be this level for example 0 and there will be different images that represent
this 0 so handwritten like images ok.
So I have just for an example I have just printed a single value from this full train
set.
So you will see that we have this tensor value so this represent different images there are
different images here and at the end you will see that there is a class value.
So there is this class so this image is from this 5 class so all the images present here
represents the 5 image handwritten.
Now let us see if we want to display this data right.
So let us just display 2 images.
So this is a very simple function that I have created.
So we are again using this matplot library and from this matplot library I am just taking
a parameter or we can call it as hyper parameter here which is show equals to 2 that we are
going to show only 2 images here.
And I am just iterating through this full train set so the training set that we were
discussing and the current image can be accessed by this so I00 right.
So I am taking 2 different classes here and of each of the class I am just going to show
the first image that we are having I think that makes it clear and I am going to print
this image value and this represents the class.
So I00 represents all the images that we are having and I01 represents the class level
of that image.
Now plot that figure this actually gives us this image we are just going to print it and
you can just copy this code from there and you can run and see what we are getting.
So you see that this is class the class name is 5 and the first image that we get is of
hand written digit 5 it looks something like S but it is 5 in reality and this is 0 the
second one that we are taking you can see that this is hand written 0.
So this is how the image data set of MNIST can be accessed if you want separately and
this is important because the like program that you will be doing for your assignment
you will need this kind of modifications in your code for it to work right.
So these are very very essential in for this particular section and you see that this images
does look like yellow, green, blue and something like that and why is it?
So these are essentially nothing but grayscale images this MNIST data set grayscale means
you have a value of 0 and 1 and between that you just give a scaling of this grayscale.
So there is only 1 channel here and that represents a value of 0 to 255 for this integer values
and 0 represents one of the extremes of black and 1 represents one of the extremes of white
and you see that here we have this grayscale image.
So how we can just plot this image in grayscale just just for showing you you can just see
map to gray which is the actual format of this file and like I am plot library does
it for you to maybe look it better.
So here you can see that this is the actual image that we were talking about.
So everything is black here everything here is black only this section is white and then
again this section is black right.
So here you will see that if this is the image this is the representation.
So image and representation look like this and we have already seen this in our matrix
thing.
Now we are going to load this data.
Now we have this raw data and we have seen how to view this raw data of image from this
library and all and now you are going to use a model for training the model right.
So for training we always require this data to be in a specific format that the model
can handle.
So Torch basically gives you this function and this data loader is a particular function
that we are talking about is a very very important function which takes any data that you have
basically raw data and it tries to transform it into a format that a model can understand
directly.
So you do not have to go through the hassle of changing it to specifically model it for
your own model.
So this train loader is nothing but our training data right now.
So it is an object of course, but this train loader now contains all the data for our training
set and how we are going to do that we are just importing this data loader from Torch
Utils library and you will see that we will give this full training set data set will
give this batch size and we will keep the shuffle.
Now why we have keep the shuffle as false is because we do not need any kind of randomness
here right.
We have already sitting all the values of Torch also for that reason.
Similarly for the test loader we are just using the exact same code and nothing else
just changing the location to test set.
So this data set is full train set we have just earlier created right this one.
So this full test set and full train set and right.
So here if we run this code you will see that we have already have this train loader and
test loader.
So these are the objects and these objects actually makes your life simpler for doing
any kind of operations using this models.
Now let us see what is this Alexian architecture.
So this architecture actually shows you this input dimension.
So this so before this convolution layer there is this input dimension we will see that in
the level below and this is a convolutional layer.
So what is a convolutional layer it essentially have all the filters right.
So this filter this tried operation and all these are already performed all performed
on this convolutional layer and you will see that there are multiple stages of this convolutional
layer in this Alexianist model.
Now there is this pooling layer also.
So what is this idea of pooling layer is that if you have these values you want to get some
of the features and you want to omit some of the features.
For example in max pooling you are going to take only the maximum values that the convolutional
layer provides and you will just omit the others.
So this way you are creating different layers and sections and once you have all this featured
extraction part where you have this convolutional pooling layer you can just feed it to this
fully connected dense layers and you can finally have an output.
So you will see that the dimension of the output here is 1 cross 10 that means we are
going to predict this 10 digits that represent in this M-list data set.
So this is a representation of for this particular work.
Now you may ask like why this is the structure, why some not is something else.
So for example there is convolutional layer 1, 2 then why not some other layers in between
and why is this.
So the idea is that the authors of this Alex-Net paper they have already discussed this thing
if you go through the paper you will get it that the specific idea behind this model was
if you make the model more deeper you are going to get much more features right.
So they proved that if you increase this deeper model so for example this convolutional layer
3, 1, 3, 2, 1, 3, 3 which is basically the depth layers.
If you do this kind of layering then the model will perform much better than a general convolutional
layer model.
So this is the general idea that was proposed in this paper and again this architecture is
very very dependent dependent on the work that you are doing depend on the images some
architecture may benefit from some of the images and some may not.
So these are the different things.
So now let us represent this image into an actual format that we can understand much
more easy and this is very important if you are going through this image processing class
right.
We must know that how this filtering and different layers can be achieved.
I think that these terms that are present here in the in this naming of the columns probably
you are familiar with it by this point.
So there is this layer and there is input layer nothing but this image that we are passing
it to the model then there is this convolutional model layer which is convolutional 2D layer
that we will call convolutional 2D and this is the max pool layer and there is different
arrangements of this layer.
And this last three layers where we are having this convolutional 2D three times is basically
the depth operation of the depth thing that discussed in this Alexinate.
So if you are having higher depth you are going to get good features and essentially
you are going to have a good classification model.
Then we have this filters right I will again explain you what this filters things actually
does here.
So here you can see this input does not have the filter or any of the other parameters
of course, but this convolutional layer it has 96 filters in the first layer.
The size of the filter is 11 essentially means it is a square filter 11 cross 11 and this
is the stride is the movement that we have already seen that we have manually done and
this padding.
So padding is essentially what is the values that you are not going to take right you are
going to pad some of the values.
So I think these are the very common terms and should not be a problem.
The feature size is the input size for this input image for this first layer basically
if the image size is 1 cross 2 to 7 cross 2 to 7.
So you will see that this is a little bit interchanged.
So here 2 to 7 2 to 7 is of course, this height and width, but this channel information is
on the left side which was previously on the right side.
So why this represented here like this because in many models if you run this models they
are represented in this way right.
So this is the general idea first is this number of features or channels whatever you
call it and then this is the resolution of this image or the dimension width and height
of this image.
And in the second layer you will see that the feature size is, filter size is 96 therefore
now instead of one feature you are having 96 different feature of the exact same image.
But the feature size will be reduced and why the feature size was reduced as we already
discussed there was a matrix and if you apply this convolutional layer you are going to
just take the center value right you are going to take the center value and this reduces
the resolution of the image and how much the resolution of the image is reduced and what
is the formula and all we will discuss that also.
So similarly we will discuss this part and you will see that this is how we actually
calculate the output size, output size is nothing but this feature size right.
So this is a simple formula formulation where you have this output size will be this lower
base for W minus F plus 2P by S which is basically this input height and width of the image which
we consider square most of the time and this filter size again we are considering it square
and this padding added to each other.
So for the initial layer we have seen that there is no padding will keep it 0 and give
the value of stride and you will get this output size.
So this will be the output size of the image that we will get right so we will get something
like 55 as an output.
So for the max pooling layer so there will be no filters of course, but we will have
a filter size so this filter size essentially does the same thing it takes the maximum values
from a 3 cross 3 matrix.
So if the filter size is 3 and stride is 2 basically it will skip 2 different cells and
this there is no padding involved here also.
And you will see that the number of filters is same therefore, the number of features
will be same here and now instead of having a 55 cross 55 resolution the resolution is
further decreased because we are again taking this center values and that is calculated using
this formulation which is w minus f by s and this thing means the exact same thing as the
previous one.
So, w minus f by s plus 1 actually gives you the output feature size or resolution for
the max pool layer or the pooling layer.
So similarly we have this max pool to the layer again after that we have this convolutional
to layer another convolutional layer and now we are seeing that there are 256 features.
And then again it has been given some filter size some stride some padding values are given
for this one and pad values might be required in some cases where the image size are not
perfectly fine with the input layers.
Because once the model is created for example, if you have created an Alex model it is not
possible for you to change it later on also.
So, so this feature size you will see now has become from 96 to 256 because now we are
having 256 features and the resolution is now 27 cross 27 because from this max pooling
layer we are not getting any kind of reduction in this dimension.
Now let us see one thing so all of this layers actually passes through this activation function
that you can see in the very right side of this cell columns.
And this is basically the really rectified linear unit activation function that we are
using for this task.
And you will see that each of this convolutional layer passes through this activation layer
and then it goes to this max pooling layer.
So this is also an important part because these are the model things that you will need
to implement in this model also.
So you have this part and again we have this classifier part.
So this is the feature extracted part which I have kept it separately because since we
were discussing that these are separate things if we are doing it separately it makes more
sense.
And this is the classifier part where we have this different layers like drop out this linear
layout and again there will be this activation functions.
And this dense layer is the final output is 10 the feature size is 10 essentially because
we want to convert it to this 10 different classes.
So we want to train this model through this 10 classes.
Now these are the overall thing that we are having and this is also one of the important
aspect the different parameters.
So we will see this parameter thing and all.
So okay so before moving on to this model I think we can take a break of 5 minutes and
then we can move ahead with this actual coding part of this AlexNet and we will train this
AlexNet model.